firme a enflammé paris vendredi dernier
entourée de ses enfants et petits
enfants à 82 ans l'icône du maloya
assuré le spectacle
invité pour cette gamme l'artiste n'a
pas hésité à faire passer pour quelqu'un
de bien mais non même si l'on nous vend
les alliés concert émouvant entraînant
donné devant des centaines de
réunionnais venus retrouver un peu de
leur île dans la grisaille parisienne
fait le rituel tous les ans bien et
c'est juste le plaisir de retrouver un
petit peu le fond le goût des gens cons
qui ont les mêmes tentations pour en
vivre en france l'équipe l'a aussi au
fait d'être au pays d'une belle lui dit
qu'une bonne ambiance des beaux bouchons
possible que à la réunion mais pour
faire un vrai qu un bon petit carry on
profite bien organisée par l'antenne de
paris l'événement se tenait à la 38
bénévoles et salariés honteux vrai
pendant des semaines pour que la fête
soit réussie
et c'est un pari gagné avec le programme
près de trois heures de spectacle pour
commémorer l'abolition de l'esclavagé de
la danse avec pour blaise
b
surprise le champion du monde de hip hop
nicolas médéa était aussi de la partie
côté musique les racines mais les ont
mis l'ambiance en voyant une bonne dose
de maloya au public sans pareil à la vie
il se passe mais ils montrent salé comme
à paris il manque un petit gros piments
voix et s'il manque un petit groupe du
mans n'est pas bon plus tôt dans la
journée l'ambiance sur quelques jus
studieuse avec un kabar la parole
l'historien bruno maillard est revenu
sur la naissance du maloya rappelant
ainsi le rôle des kabars à l'époque
donné scannage c'était non seulement un
moyen pour les esclaves de naître ce se
retrouver un peu autour de musique de
danse et de chant mais aussi de débattre
d'un certain nombre de sujets et surtout
d'entretenir cette résistance
longtemps interdit sur l'île le maloya
est devenu en 2009 patrimoine culturel
immatériel de l'humanité
c'est en tout cas autour de cette
musique que les réunionnais de paris se
sont retrouvés
car la fête kaf c'est avant tout un
moment de partage de rencontre et bien
sûr de mémoire pour plus léger de
christie mitterrand le 20 décembre à
l'antenne de paris pour la réunion sous
votre table